Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Un challenge,
cela peut avoir l’air impossible,
mais il résonne en nous
pour que nous trouvions la force
de le rendre possible.
La vie est une enfilade de challenges
à réaliser, de défis à relever.
Seul -
(Applaudissements)
Ce peut être à l’image d’une course,
comme la natation.
On nage, on nage, encore, encore.
Tant d’énergie à fournir.
Mais quel est le but ?
Quel est le sens ?
Vous voulez savoir quel était
mon quotidien à l’âge de douze ans ?
Réveil à 4 h du matin pour commencer
un entraînement de 2 heures,
filer au collège, en cours,
ne pas se relâcher.
Puis enchaîner
sur le deuxième entraînement,
puis finir la journée par les devoirs
et le coucher à 20h30.
Vous trouvez cela contraignant ?
Écoutez-moi bien.
À 18 ans, je quitte ma terre natale,
la Guyane française.
Je pars à plus de 8 000 kilomètres
de chez moi.
À Paris, seule dans la grisaille.
Changement d'environnement total.
Alors oui, vous pouvez
trouver cela contraignant.
Tant d’efforts, tant de sacrifices
qui m’ont menée
à l’Institut National des Sports,
de l’Expertise et de la Performance,
l’INSEP, le centre qui forme
les plus grands champions français.
Dix ans après cet
investissement pré-adolescent,
je suis qualifiée aux Jeux olympiques.
Alors si c'était à refaire,
je le referais.
Qualifiée aux Jeux olympiques.
Comme le disait LeBron James :
« N’ayez pas peur de l’échec,
c’est un moyen de réussir. »
Aux Jeux olympiques,
100 mètres nage libre.
Je me retrouve
avec la médaille en chocolat.
Justement, l'échec.
Rongée de rage, de colère,
je n’avais qu’une envie :
aller chercher une médaille.
En larmes face aux journalistes,
je n’avais qu’une phrase :
« Les autres nageuses
ont intérêt de s’accrocher. »
21 août 2004.
Finale du 50 mètres nage libre.
Je suis au couloir 3.
Pendant ma course,
je décide de ne pas respirer.
Perte de temps.
À douze mètres de l’arrivée,
je suis septième, loin.
Le podium m'échappe.
Je touche le mur.
Vice-championne olympique.
Une gloire, trop contente.
Fière de représenter la France
et de revenir avec une médaille.
Un an plus tard,
je suis qualifiée aux championnats
du monde qui se déroulent à Montréal.
Début de championnat catastrophique.
Je pleure dans mes lunettes
à l'entraînement.
Je ne mange plus.
Trois jours de cauchemar.
Puis je me qualifie pour la finale
du 100 mètres nage libre.
J’avais trois consignes :
rester au contact avec
les nageuses aux premiers 50,
un virage rapide,
puis accélération jusqu’à l’arrivée.
Je décide de me battre jusqu’au
bout en mémoire de mon père,
décédé deux ans plus tôt.
Je touche le mur.
Vice-championne du monde
sur l’épreuve reine.
Une revanche.
Deux mois plus tard,
je suis stoppée dans mon élan
de victoire et de podium.
Blessure.
Inflammation du cartilage du thorax.
Impossible de m'entraîner.
Je vais souffrir de cette douleur
pendant plus d'un an et demi.
Six mois plus tard,
je suis touchée par la gale.
Après, trois années
de réflexion vont venir
sur ma carrière
de sportive de haut niveau.
Est-ce que j’ai toujours cette envie ?
Est-ce que je suis toujours passionnée ?
Est-ce que je peux tenir
cette charge mentale et physique ?
Eh bien, en octobre 2009,
je décide d’arrêter ma carrière.
Je n'ai plus d'envie.
Plus de rage.
Rejet complet de l'odeur du chlore.
Et là va arriver un nouveau challenge
sur mon avenir.
Je finis mon école de journalisme.
Diplôme en poche,
la reconversion va s’avérer beaucoup
plus compliquée que prévu.
Je suis face à un fossé.
Comment faire pour passer
de l’autre côté ?
Pourtant, j'ai le matériel
pour construire ce pont.
Mais personne pour m'accompagner.
Pourtant, j’ai l’intime conviction
que tout a un sens,
que rien n’arrive par hasard.
2021.
La crise sanitaire touche le monde entier.
Fin du premier confinement.
Je reçois un appel pas comme les autres.
On me propose
la traversée du lac Titicaca.
122 kilomètres à la nage
en tractant un radeau de 500 kilos
avec Théo Curin, nageur paralympique
amputé des quatre membres,
et Mathieu Witvoet, éco-aventurier.
J’ai rigolé quand on me l’a proposé :
« Moi sprinteuse,
faire 122 kilomètres
avec un radeau de 500 kilos,
à 3 800 mètres d’altitude,
donc 30 % d’oxygène en moins ? »
Travail d'équipe.
Dépassement de soi.
Un nouveau monde qui s'ouvre
à moi, le côté aventure.
Une heure et demie après cet appel,
j’accepte.
Vous allez me dire :
« Pourquoi ? Mais elle est folle ! »
Parce que ce projet partage mes valeurs.
Le handicap,
montrer que tout est possible.
L’écologie, un radeau conçu
à partir de matériaux recyclés.
La solidarité,
nous sommes trois dans cette aventure
dans les bons comme
dans les mauvais moments.
Nous allons passer
quinze mois de préparation.
Stage en altitude,
adaptation à l’eau froide,
entraînement dans de l’eau à 6°C,
des bains dans de l’eau à 9°C,
dormir dans des chambres hypoxiques -
donc simulation de la haute altitude -
et le plus important :
dormir à trois.
Donc une personne qui ronfle,
une personne qui pète en dormant
et une personne qui pète toute la journée.
Je ne vous dis pas qui fait quoi.
10 novembre 2021.
Le jour du départ.
Cela va nous réserver beaucoup
de surprises dès la deuxième nuit.
Nous sommes dans une baie paradisiaque.
Le seul moment de réconfort,
c'est le dîner.
Et là, nous apercevons
des orages, des éclairs,
comme dirait Théo, une boulangerie.
Et là,
la grêle, un bruit infernal
sur la coque de la tente.
Impossible de dormir.
Le lendemain,
impossible de partir.
Beaucoup trop de vent.
Nous restons immobiles toute la journée.
Puis va arriver la cinquième nuit.
La pire.
Le vent se lève.
Des vagues de plus en plus grandes.
1m50, voire deux mètres.
Nous enfilant nos gilets de sauvetage,
accrochés au radeau
grâce à nos sangles de nage.
Mathieu, capitaine du radeau,
garde le couteau de survie à la main.
Si on chavire,
la côte la plus proche
est à dix kilomètres.
Les gardes côtiers mettront plus
de 4 heures à venir nous retrouver.
Nous restons éveillés toute la nuit.
Mais nous venons de connaître le pire.
Il ne nous reste plus
qu’à découvrir le meilleur.
Le jour de l'arrivée.
Au loin, nous apercevons notre équipe,
la population, vêtue d’habits
traditionnels de couleur jaune-bleu-rouge.
Un moment magique.
J’ai des larmes, des frissons,
comme lors de ma finale olympique.
Je serre très fort
mes camarades d’aventure.
Nous sommes trois audacieux
qui ont parcouru 108 kilomètres
en onze jours, dix nuits.
Mark Twain disait :
« Ils ne savaient pas que c’était
impossible, alors ils l’ont fait. »
Eh oui, mesdames et messieurs,
si vous aussi, il vous est arrivé
de vous sentir perdu,
de ne plus savoir quel est le sens,
challenges à réaliser, défis à relever,
seront pour vous une façon d'avancer.
Et vous,
quel est votre prochain challenge ?
(Applaudissements)